what's up guys welcome to another  episode of challenge pongfinity today  we'll try out these cricket bats leave  your ideas and comments in the comment  section below  [Music]  no you're  gonna see  [Music]  this is  [Music]  [Applause]  let's try playing with the cricket bats  huh  [Music]  how did you miss it  that was all right then  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  that's a scary shot  [Music]  first base  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  huh  [Music]  [Applause]  okay  okay we're gonna play a game of table  tennis cricket  hey you have to start running  [Music]  do i get a point for hitting your shoes  [Music]  i did it  one point  [Music]  i think i broke it  [Music]  i think i was the winner of  table tennis cricket  i don't think so yeah i was clearing the  way yeah you can believe it yourself if  you want to